hey this was a very strange moment
yesterday uh joe biden
incorrectly said
that he has cancer and this was you know
hours before we learned that he has
covered but this was apparently just
sort of like uh he used the wrong word
and said had rather than have cancer but
this set off
a firestorm and frenzy of did biden just
casually admit to having cancer my
mother drove us and rather than us be
able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you knew what was
happening
you had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i had so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer and why
can't for the longest time delaware had
the highest cancer rate in the nation so
he does say i and so many other people i
grew up with have cancer
he clearly means
had in his particular case
and immediately multiple reports coming
out saying what on earth is joe biden
talking about and the white house saying
it's a reference to when he had skin
cancer years ago
um mostly right-wing media outlets
initially jumping on it one of the first
reports was from the new york post which
is owned by news corporation joe biden
says he has cancer thanks to the oil
industry but the white house points to
skin cancer years ago
president biden said wednesday he had
cancer forcing the white house press
office to clarify he's referring to skin
cancer treatment he had before taking
office last year
it's unclear
what that
type of cancer specifically has to do
with oil but just sort of a confusing
hour or two the washington examiner also
white house denies biden has new cancer
diagnosis
um
the president the biden's latest
presidential bill of health notes that
prior to entering office he had a number
of cancerous lesions removed quote it's
well established biden spent a good deal
of time in the sun in his youth he's had
several localized non-melanoma skin
cancers removed
with mohs surgery before he started his
presidency there are no areas suspicious
for skin cancer uh at this time
and i guess quickly resolved but a few
moments there of serious confusion
um we've got the clip you can make of it
what you will on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show after this
short break
i will be speaking to arthur brooks
arthur brooks was last on the show like
15 years ago when he was a professional
right winger he is in a much different
area of practice at this point i guess
we could say that's after the break
remember tuesday july 26th is our next
viewer town hall i hope you will join
everyone's welcome to call in and speak
to me it will be streaming live on the
pacman live youtube channel
youtube.compacmanlive
and um it'll be at 6pm east
3 p.m west tuesday july 26th
all of us have had the experience of
dropping out of an important zoom call
because of a flaky wi-fi connection i've
had it when live streaming if you can
think of something more humiliating let
me know uh something else i struggle
with is when i'm on the go
finding a good enough connection to
upload or download large video files
which i regularly need to do what if you
could fix all of this by using more than
one internet connection at the same time
like the coffee shop wi-fi
and your mobile phones connection
combining them into one super internet
connection that's faster and more
reliable our sponsor speedify is the
only app that can combine multiple
internet sources into one
fantastic
super connection like this this will
improve your live streaming your video
calling your gaming the web browsing
everything you do online
use speedify on all devices pc mac
iphone android linux works with any type
of internet connection simple to use
runs in the background i use it
everywhere especially when traveling
and it works great try speedify risk
free
for seven days and get 20 off go to
speedify.com pacman and use the code
pacman click the link down in the
description